tell me why did you decide to be on
Dancing with the Stars and what are you
concerned about I decided to be on
Dancing with the Stars because I really
need dance lessons and and so to be
offered dance lessons from these amazing
dancers is like I know it's such an
opportunity for me I I always wanted to
be able to dance and so I think it's
going to be so much fun what's the
toughest part of the competition is it
the training is it the schedule well I
know it's gonna be a tough schedule you
know I know that it's like we start out
I pretty much like you just kind of go
to work right away we're gonna start on
Monday or Tuesday I'm not sure yet
everything is last-minute it seems and
and we'll be working in the beginning
you work about five hours a day
rehearsing and just a few little breaks
here and there and then I think then the
schedule goes they have a full-on dress
rehearsal the day before the actual show
so I'm anticipating that those two days
are going to be you know the the
challenging days or the most I like to
look at is the most exciting days you
know because you get to really feel it
all out be in the costumes get the vibe
and so I don't know I think I'm I'm just
looking at the whole thing as a big
barrel of fun you've been practicing or
training before the competition of you
started I know you're not allowed to
they told us that we weren't allowed to
start training until next week so I
followed the rules but a number of
people have said to me you know even on
TV like Kel was sitting next to me he
goes oh my wife and I she trains me
every night it's like okay Kel
definitely surviving me and then
and then well a lot of people that I
spoke to and everybody seems to have had
some sort of training so I don't stand a
shot but I'm not gonna let that stop me
and I think that's the important thing
is to just there we go and have the time
of your life and learn something new and
that's what I'm here for